JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All right.
Good morning everyone.
Quick introductions.
My name is Jarek Wilkiewicz.
I'm a Developer Advocate
with YouTube.
And here with me is Doug Muir.
He's a Technical Director
from Activision.
And we also have Cliff Samaniego
and Kenji Arai from
YouTube who will be joining
us for Q&A later in this
presentation.
So the agenda for today.
We just went through
the introductions.
I will talk a little bit about
why would one want to
integrate a game title
with YouTube.
And then what is the process of
integration, so how do you
actually get that done.
And discuss the one use case in
more detail, namely Call of
Duty: Black Ops.
For those of you that are
gamers, this game needs no
introduction.
And for those of you that
aren't, let me just say that
it was the biggest
game of 2010.
And they made an incredible
amount of money on that game.
What I would like to start with
is a little quiz to kind
of wake you up and see how much
you know about YouTube.
I'm sure all of you guys are
users, but I always like to
test knowledge of my audience.
So question number one is--
it should be pretty easy-- how
many views do we get per day
on YouTube?
Any guesses?
2, 3, 10 million?
1 million.
200 million.
A billion-ish.
OK.
So actually it's
over 2 billion.
And this is data
from last year.
Next question.
So out of the 2 billion, how
many are mobile, so used on
mobile devices?
What do you guys think?
25%.
30%.
10%.
Yeah, it's actually
over 200 million.
So it's over 10%.
This number is also growing
pretty fast.
Last question.
How much video is uploaded
each and
every minute to YouTube?
How many hours?
20 hours.
OK.
Do I have 24?
26.
It's actually over 35 hours.
Which brings us to this
presentation because we'll be
talking about uploading videos
to YouTube from a game.
So why would anybody want to
integrate with YouTube?
First of all, the site is
very international.
We have hundreds of
millions of users.
And over 70% of traffic
comes from outside
of the United States.
So if you want to target global
audience, putting
content up on YouTube is
a good way to do this.
Gaming is one of our
top verticals.
And we find that gamers are very
engaged, so they create,
share, discover new content
and socialize on YouTube.
And we like that because that
really helps drive community
engagement around the content
that you put up on YouTube.
As Doug was going to talk about
a little later in the
presentation, YouTube gives
you a mechanism to promote
your title.
And you can monetize some of
that content as well and thus
grow your community, grow the
excitement around your title.
So we talked a little bit about
why to go through this
process of YouTube
integration.
Since we are developers here,
let's talk a little bit about
the APIs, and how does
one actually do this.
So first of all, to upload a
video to YouTube there's three
steps that one has
to go through.
First, the video needs
to be encoded.
And there are various encoding
technologies available.
So I know that two of them here
that are quite popular,
H.264 and WebM VP8.
Once the video is encoded, we
provide data APIs that can be
used to actually push the
video over to YouTube
programmatically.
So again this is not going to
youtube.com and uploading this
manually, all we talked about
here are the APIs.
And then finally, we have
a set of player APIs.
So if you would like to build
say a video portal around the
content that you have uploaded,
you can use the
player APIs to customize the
playback experience.
And I'll talk a little bit more
about each one of these
in the following slides.
So starting with encoding.
Some platforms have H.264
encoding built in.
In the case of platforms
that don't--
for example, on the Xbox,
there was no encoding
available during
the integration
process for Black Ops.
We have WebM, which is an
open source project.
It is really designed for web
video, so it provides pretty
efficient compression and
streaming capability.
So you can achieve pretty high
quality streaming at
relatively low bandwidth.
So as I showed here,
360p at 280Kpbs
or 720p at 1.5 megabit.
The technology performs quite
well on platforms that don't
have hardware offloading.
Some platforms do have it, but
they don't necessarily expose
it through the APIs, Mobilis
is one case.
It's open source, so you can
just fetch it from WebM
Project and try it out.
And typically video file
consists of encoded video with
VP8 and audio also encoded.
I wanted to mention Ogg Vorbis
which is also an open source
code that you can use to kind of
combine the two and create
a video ready for upload.
So we created a video, rendered
frames, compressed
it, encoded it, and now we
are ready to upload.
So how do we do that?
YouTube offers Google
data APIs.
For those of you that haven't
worked with data APIs, just a
quick overview.
They are based on REST, so they
are very easy to use.
Really designed around
HTTP protocols.
Based on ATOM.
We tried to follow a couple of
RFC in the API design that
kind of dictate how do you
map an object model to a
REST-based implementation.
I mentioned RFCs here.
If you guys have
trouble falling
asleep, I recommend these.
They are better than
counting sheep.
I actually like reading
RFCs myself.
So for me, it's kind of fun to
kind of check out how the
design was actually driven
by these standards.
And we support XML-based
encoding.
So this is the representation of
the actual data, as well as
JSON, JSON-C and RSS.
JSON, JSON-C are very relevant
for JavaScript developers, but
also in the mobile context.
Where you really care about
the amount of information
exchanged, JSON-C is
a very efficient
representation of the data.
So that's something that you can
request. When you make the
REST request to our API, you can
actually tell it what type
of representation you
would like to fetch.
The data that we expose is
organized as a set of feeds.
Each feed has a bunch
of entries.
So for example, video feed
will have entries
corresponding to individual
videos.
Subscription feed will have
entries corresponding to
individual subscriptions.
And applications integrate with
the YouTube platform by
basically interacting
with these feeds.
So entries can be deleted,
created, queried and so forth.
And that's typically how
an integration works.
So let's look at a API
invocation example.
Since I mentioned that the
protocol is based on REST,
really all I need to do in order
to invoke the YouTube
API is issue an HTTP get
request to our URL,
which I just did.
And I basically asked it to
show me all the top rated
videos on YouTube.
And what you see here is an XML
representation, which is
the default ATOM
representation.
I could have asked for
JSON or JSON-C.
Each entry corresponds to
a video from this feed.
And there's additional metadata
information available
about each of these entries.
So I have a playback URL if I
want to play the video back.
There is description,
tags and so forth.
So as you see, invoking the
API is quite simple.
You can do it directly
over HTTP.
We also provide gdata libraries
that abstract this
process out.
So if you don't want to do XML
parsing or JSON parsing, you
want higher level abstractions,
we have open
source libraries for that.
So again, this is kind
of zooming in
on one of the results.
What you see here is the feed
that's got a closing entity.
And then each one of
these videos is
represented as an entry.
I'm highlighting here video
ID as one of the important
attributes of this video.
And that's pretty much how one
interacts with most of the
gdata APIs, Google Data
APIs for YouTube.
So the process of uploading the
video really follows the
same pattern.
So how do we actually upload
the video from a game?
We offer several upload APIs.
Browser-based API, direct upload
API, direct API and
direct resumable API.
The browser-based approach
doesn't really apply in our
case here because we are talking
about integration from
a game title and installed
application.
It is typically used for web
applications where you would
like to allow the user to upload
a video to YouTube, but
you want to take control over
the entire experience.
You don't want them to
ever leave your site.
You can use the browser-based
approach.
In this case, we are talking
about integration directly
from an application.
And for that, we have two set
of APIs, direct and direct
resumable uploads.
Really the important difference
between these two
is direct resumable, it's very
applicable to mobile context
or situations where your
connectivity can come and go.
Because what direct resumable
uploads allows you to do is if
your connectivity goes down, you
can actually pick up from
where you left off.
This way you don't have to kind
of restart the entire
upload process.
One thing that is important that
I wanted to highlighted
is we have to authenticate in
order to upload a video on
behalf of the user.
Historically, ClientLogin was
kind of the authentication
method of choice.
But recently the industry has
really moved away from
ClientLogin for many reasons
and instead has adopted an
AuthSub, OAuth 2.0 or OAuth
2.0 device profile-based
authorization model.
And what that allows you to do
is really to fetch a token
that you can use in order to
perform API operations on
behalf of the user.
But you never actually
have to store the
username and password.
And it's nice not to have to
do that because if, for
whatever reason, you encounter
any kind of security breach,
the only thing that one could
actually obtain is that token
that is only valid for a
specific subset of the data
that the user has access to.
And that token can very easy
be revoked by the user.
So I wanted to take a little
time and talk about OAuth 2.0
device profile, which is
something that we have
launched into beta
very recently.
The problem that OAuth 2.0
device profile tries to solve
is how do you actually provide
a nice user experience on
platforms that typically don't
have a web browser.
So what I'm trying to do is I
would like to invoke a method
or service that gives me access
to a token, which I can
then use to perform API
operations on behalf of the
user, but I don't have a web
browser on my device.
So say I'm on a gaming
console--
some kind of an embedded device,
a TV or what not--
so OAuth 2.0 device profile
attempts to solve this problem
by really setting up a flow,
which at some point takes the
user away from their couch, so
they go and use a web browser
in order to obtain the
application token or authorize
the device access
to their data.
So let's quickly walk
through the flow.
So what to see here is on the
left hand side, I have the
device client.
So that could be gaming console,
TV, some kind of an
embedded device without
a browser.
On the right hand side, I have
an authorization server, which
is something that we have
implemented, and other people
in the industry are implementing
that as well.
And the first step of this
sequence is that the device
client actually asks the
authorization server to
initiate the authorization
sequence by supplying a client
identifier.
A client identifier is something
that you can
actually obtain through
our API console.
So when you actually register
your application with Google,
you can say that this is the
application name, this is
image or thumbnail that you
would like to show to the user
when they attempt to perform
an authorization flow.
And then the client
identifier is
something you get in exchange.
This is what the device client
must know in order to actually
initiate this sequence.
So really identifies the
application as well.
So once the client identifier
is submitted to the
authorization server, the
authorization server returns a
verification code.
So you can think of it as a
PIN code that the user can
then use in order to authorize
this device to access the
user's data.
And in addition to the
verification code, user code
is returned in the
verification URI.
The verification URI identifies
the place on the
net where the user has
to go in order to
complete the sequence.
So what you see is the next
step in the sequence is C,
where the user will
visit a site--
again that's the site that
is identified by the
verification URI--
and authorize access to the
user's data upon which the
device will be able to retrieve
the authorization
token and proceed.
So while step C is taking
place, step E--
the verification code
reattempt--
is initiated by the
device client.
So it's basically a
polling mechanism.
The device will keep polling
until the user
authorizes the access.
Then when the user actually
authenticates, authorizes the
access, the device will obtain
the access token in step F.
And from then on, that token
can be used to actually
perform API operations.
So that's kind of the big
difference between how things
are typically done with
ClientLogin, where somebody
tries to type username and
password in front of a TV that
maybe doesn't have a keyboard,
or they're on a gaming console
where typically web browsers are
really not a part of their
experience because it's not
optimized for that.
So this OAuth 2.0 device
profile tries
to solve this problem.
So let's look through a quick
demo of how this thing works
in practice.
So I built a small application
here that performs the
authorization flow.
And I'm using my favorite
terminal emulator from the
'80s called Cathode.
So let's just start
the sequence.
So what you see here is this
part would be executed by the
embedded device, so TV or gaming
console or whatever.
The authorization server
was contacted.
And the token returned
by it is shown and
embedded in this URL.
In practice, we will actually
shorten the URL.
So right now you see it's
sandbox.google.com.
It's a little long.
We'll come up with something
shorter.
But the idea here is that the
user will be presented with
this code and the URL.
Then they go to a website
actually identified by the URL
and type in the code.
So let's try to do that.
So I followed that URL.
I am presented with a prompt
saying, device is requesting
permission to connect
with my account.
Hit continue.
I don't need to update.
And then what I see is my
application, which I
registered.
So I mentioned earlier that you
can provide a thumbnail
that identifies the
application, the
title and so on.
So this application is asking
for permission in order to
access my YouTube account.
I will grant access.
OK.
Now that I have done this, you
have noticed that the polling
has stopped.
So my client application
successfully obtained the
authorization token.
And then I will complete
the upload.
Yeah.
So this process now performs a
resumable upload of a video
that I had on my local
machine to YouTube.
That upload was actually done
into my account using the
authorization token that this
polling client obtained from
the authorization server
on my behalf.
So you saw that in this embedded
environment that I'm
showing here, there was
no web browser.
So doing any sort of user
experience based on web
browser wouldn't have worked.
But with OAuth 2.0 device
profile, I can actually still
implement that.
So we talked about
video encoding.
We have the video.
We uploaded it to youtube.com
using the API.
Now let's talk a little
bit about player APIs.
And how can we customize
playback behavior with our
player APIs?
So we offer three ways to
customize the player and the
playback behavior, URI
parameter, JavaScript API, and
ActionScript API.
So let's quickly walk
through them.
The simplest way to influence
how the player
works is player parameter.
So in the top example,
I have a parameter
called FullScreen, fs=0.
So by appending this parameter
to my embed source, what will
happen is that the user will not
have an option to actually
pop up the video in
full screen mode.
So again if you are designing
an application, which for
whatever reason doesn't want
to grant the user access to
full screen playback because
you always want them to see
your web application, you can
actually do that by appending
a player parameter
to the embed.
So it's very simple.
On the bottom, I have
an example of
another parameter, autoplay.
What that will do is when the
user navigates to a page,
which includes this embed, the
video embedded on the page
will start playing right away.
And one thing to notice, the
syntax of the bottom embed is
something that we have
introduced fairly recently.
It's the iframe embed.
It is kind of the default
embed right
now for YouTube videos.
And we have a session about
details of this
implementation, how it
works, tomorrow.
So we talked about the
player parameters.
But sometimes you actually want
much finer control over
what the playback experience
is like.
And for that, we actually have
a JavaScript API and
ActionScript API.
So if you are a Flash developer,
you can invoke
methods on the player to start
playback, stop playback,
register for events
and so forth.
And you can do the same
thing with JavaScript.
So here's an example where I'm
actually creating an instance
of a player registering to a
couple of events and really
what I'm trying to achieve is
I want the video to start
playing as soon as someone
navigates to the page.
That excuses this JavaScript.
And then I want the playback
to stop after 15 seconds.
So let's try that.
Maybe we crank up the volume.
[MUSIC PLAYING --
THE ROLLING STONES,
"GIMME SHELTER"]
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So if you look
through the code, really
what I did here is I embedded
this video.
This is the video ID that I was
showing you earlier in the
presentation.
I registered two events on
ready, which is called--
this event gets actually fired
when player is ready to
receive API invocations
and on state change.
When player is ready, I trigger
the video playback.
And upon state change, when the
playback starts, I set up
a timer, which will fire and
trigger the video to stop
after 15 seconds.
So I can very easily change
that to say five seconds.
Let's see.
Nothing interesting happens.
But I think you get the point
that you can actually control
the playback behavior through
the player API.
So we talked about the
APIs and platform
integration and so forth.
So now I would like to let Doug
talk a little bit more
about Black Ops.
But first a question.
How many of you guys have
actually played the game?
Fair amount, but I see some
folks that haven't.
So why don't we look at the
game trailer to give you a
little better idea of what
the game is all about.
And then Doug will take you
through the integration
process that he went through
with his team.
[MUSIC PLAYING--
THE ROLLING STONES,
"GIMME SHELTER"]
DOUG MUIR: I'm Doug Muir.
I'm a Technical Director at
Activision, the company that
published Call of
Duty: Black Ops.
And I'm here to talk a little
bit about the theater feature
for Call of Duty: Black
Ops, and how it
integrates with YouTube.
But first I want to talk about
what we were trying to do.
The primary thing we were trying
to do with the theater
functionality and allowing
people to upload their videos
to YouTube is we were trying to
let people share their cool
moments in the game.
You do something neat, you get
five kills in a row, you take
out a helicopter with a
Tomahawk, you want to tell
your buddies about it.
You want to show them how that
happened, how that worked.
And so YouTube is a great way
for us to let people share
those cool moments
with each other.
In those terms, we were sort
of looking at two things.
We were looking to let our
existing community connect
with each other and share
these cool moments.
But we were also looking to
expose Call of Duty to players
who haven't gotten into
the game yet.
And we obviously wanted all the
reporting and engagement
and analysis that we could get,
but we didn't want to
have to build YouTube to
get all this stuff.
So the uploading process.
The user experience for it is
not the OAuth 2.0 device
profile that Jarek just
walked you through.
A, that wasn't available when
we did this integration.
And B, as I'll talk about a
little bit later, we came to
the YouTube party
a little late.
And the game was pretty much
baked at that point.
We wouldn't have been able to
integrate anything for the
device profile integration
anyway.
But here's a short video sort
of showing the process for
uploading a clip from Call of
Duty: Black Ops to YouTube.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Hey everyone.
It's Anoj.
And right now I have a tutorial
on how to get your
Black Op clips onto your
YouTube account
and onto your computer.
And I know some people already
know how to do this, but if
you don't, I hope this video
is going to be helpful.
The only things that you need
are an Xbox 360 or PS3, the
game itself, an internet
connection
and a YouTube account.
And the greatest thing about
this method is that it
requires no capture
card, cables,
wires or editing software.
And most importantly, this
process is absolutely free.
I'm going to go step by step,
starting with the things you
need to do on the internet and
then move on to the things you
need to do with your
Xbox or PS3.
The first step is to go to
callofduty.com and register an
account there.
Once you do that, go to
callofduty.com/theater and
link your gamertag, which will
require you using your
Windows Live ID.
Now go back to
callofduty.com/theater.
And on that page, click to link
your YouTube account, and
then click to allow access
to your YouTube account.
If you don't allow access,
this whole
process will not work.
Now switch over to your Xbox
360 or PS3, and go into
multiplayer and then
into theater.
Select the game play
that you want.
And while you are watching that
game, find a segment you
want to capture and
select record.
[VIDEO GAME DIALOG AND SOUNDS]
-When you have reached the end
of the clip segment that you
want to capture, hit
record again.
A very important note here,
your clip cannot be longer
than 30 seconds, or it
will not be uploaded.
Next, you have to name the clip,
save it and upload it to
a slot on your Fileshare.
Now get out of viewing the full
game, and then take your
clip from your Fileshare, and
click select for playback.
After that, you'll notice
that the render clip
option is now available.
So click on that.
And then the clip will
be opened and
will run through once.
After, you will see a loading
screen for the clip, which
means it's being uploaded and
rendered to the internet.
After a couple hours, your clip
should be uploaded to
your YouTube account and
to your Fileshare on
callofduty.com/theater.
This process does take some
time, so don't expect your
clip to be there as soon as the
rendering has finished.
So in other words, try to be
as patient as possible.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
DOUG MUIR: So that's the flow.
And you can see it sort of
uses the normal web-based
OAuth flow.
And we'll talk a little
bit about the details
a little bit later.
But how did we end up here?
Where we started actually
was we weren't
thinking YouTube at all.
We were thinking, OK we have
this cool feature.
We can let people share their
clips in the game.
And you saw a little
bit of that.
We have the Fileshare in the
game, and people can download
the clips and look
at it from there.
But we wanted to let people
share outside of our world of
callofduty.com.
So our first plan was actually
we were going to put the clips
available on callofduty.com.
So you could go to
callofduty.com, find your
clip, download it, and then do
whatever you wanted with it.
Upload it to YouTube, send it
your grandma, whatever.
But that's really kind of a
horrible user experience.
So the next sort of evolution
of our thinking was we would
turn callofduty.com into
a video streaming site.
We would serve the videos.
We would have to do some
transcoding especially on the
Xbox videos.
Again sort of due to the
lateness with which we came to
YouTube, we were not using WebM
when the game launched.
We were using Motion JPEG on the
Xbox actually because that
was the quickest free
codec for us to
integrate with the game.
As we were working through this
idea of streaming the
videos from callofduty.com, we
started asking ourselves, how
much video are we talking
about here?
Call of Duty is a
pretty big game.
We expected Black Ops
to do very well.
And in fact Black Ops
has sold north of 20
million units so far.
As we started thinking about the
size of the community, and
how much video we might be
taking on here, we realized,
this is not Activision's
core competency.
Let's find somebody who
does this pretty well.
And that's when we thought
of YouTube.
Again, because we came YouTube
so late, I think we first
started talking to them about
doing this integration
sometime in September
for a game that was
launching in November.
We really had no way of
doing any sort of
account linking in game.
Because of that, because we
couldn't link your account in
game, we wanted to have a good
user experience for users who
haven't linked their account.
We didn't want you to go
theater, and your first time
trying to render a movie have
to tell you, sorry you don't
have your YouTube
account link.
You can't upload.
We wanted something to happen
even for users who hadn't yet
linked their YouTube accounts,
or who didn't want a YouTube
account for whatever reason.
They just wanted to share
their video and not will
bother with a YouTube account.
After spending some time talking
to YouTube, we came up
with these per-platform Call
of Duty channels, sort of
catch-all accounts for
people who haven't
linked their accounts.
And we upload the videos to
those channels on behalf of
these sort of role users,
these fictional users.
And that actually worked
pretty well.
So this is how the flow works.
You build your clip on
your Xbox, your PS3.
You upload it.
It actually goes to DemonWare,
which is the Activision studio
that handles all of the
multi-player backends for all
Activision titles.
They handle matchmaking.
They handle stats, backends,
everything.
And we go to DemonWare, A,
because we did this very late,
and we were already talking
to DemonWare.
But B, some of the first parties
have some policy rules
about talking to just anybody
out on the internet.
So to work around those policy
issues, the easiest thing to
do was to just send it
to DemonWare first.
Which actually turned out to be
very convenient in terms of
account linking.
Because in the user flow that we
saw a little while ago for
linking your YouTube account,
that token that we get back,
the OAuth token is actually
stored at DemonWare.
And it's associated with
your consul identity.
So when the video hits
DemonWare, they look up for
the user that you're playing
as, do they have an OAuth
token for you.
And if so, they upload that
video to YouTube under your
account for you.
If not, then they go to one of
these shared accounts, which
get a lot of videos.
And all the videos eventually
end up at YouTube.
And if you have linked your
account, it ends up in the
right place.
And from there, you can watch
the videos directly on
YouTube, or you can go to
callofduty.com/theater and
find your videos there and watch
them there if that's
what you like to do.
So the benefits of integrating
for us.
The big one was actually
the ROI.
And it's not so much that we
made a ton of money from the
YouTube views is that we saved
so much money by not having to
build it ourselves.
So rather than having to spend
all the money to engineer a
solution for the transcoding
and streaming and buildout,
the serving infrastructure for
handling what we expected was
going to be sort of a very
longtail distribution of
views, we were able to push all
that work off on YouTube
and have them pay us a little
bit, which was a huge net win.
In terms of user engagement,
it's been working very well.
Since the game launched on
November 9, we've had over 3.6
million uploads of videos to
people's own YouTube channels
and the shared YouTube
channels.
Nearly 70 million total views.
And it's something that this
is a true community-based
marketing opportunity for
lack of a better word.
We get PR.
We get community buzz.
We get people sharing
their videos,
talking about the game.
You go to YouTube, and you
search for Call of Duty: Black
Ops, there's a ton of
videos basically
advertising our game.
It's fantastic.
Here are some of the key
insights from the views and
the uploads.
I'm not going to read it.
Some of the interesting ones are
the male/female breakdown
is just about what you might
expect for a game
like Call of Duty.
Most of the traffic is actually
coming from YouTube.
The vast majority
of the traffic
is coming from YouTube.
Either people going to the Call
of Duty channel pages or
just searching for Call
of Duty and finding
the videos that way.
In terms of player behavior, the
thing that was interesting
to us was for a feature that--
as you saw from the video
outlining how you upload
videos-- for a feature that's
kind of buried in the UI,
we've had 580,000 plus players
upload videos.
And most of them actually have
uploaded more than one.
So it's not something where most
players are going in and
uploading one video and then
giving up on the future.
Over 80,000 players
have uploaded more
than 10 videos each.
And we've got one user who, as
of late April, he'd uploaded
over 500 videos.
So that guy's working at a clip
of about three a day.
Which we think is great.
I mean that sort of validates
our whole thinking in terms of
the feature.
We expected that there would be
sort of that creative core,
who would really get
into the future and
produce a lot of videos.
But we also wanted to build
something that the more casual
user would use.
And we think that the usage
stats are sort of
bearing that out.
In terms of views, this slide
just blows me away.
Well over 90% of the videos have
had less than 100 views
since November 15.
Which, when you think of the
average age of the videos,
that's less than one
view per day.
There's no way that we would
have been in a position to
handle that number of views,
building out an
infrastructure ourselves.
Akamai or any other CDN would
not have helped with 90% of
the views that we would
have had to serve.
So having YouTube and their
scale and their serving
capability was a huge
win for us.
I mean the number of of videos
with over 100,000 views is 36.
The distribution is just
frightening for anybody who
would be trying to build a
system like this themselves.
In terms of what went right.
I mean like I said, we started
this in September for a game
that was shipping in November.
And this was ready to go on
November 9 when Call of Duty:
Black Ops hit store shelves.
The way I think about it, it was
actually ready on November
8 when the game started
launching in Australia.
I mean that was a
huge win for us.
The technical support
that we got
from YouTube was fantastic.
The API docks and the
public forums
answered most of our questions.
The developer support was
fantastic when it didn't.
And really once we launched,
except for one issue where we
didn't know to watch the
YouTube maintenance
notifications--
so there was one window when
YouTube went into a read-only
mode, and we didn't
know about it.
And so we started panicking
because our writes were
failing, our uploads
were failing.
Except for that, we haven't had
any issues since this went
live in November after
3.6 million uploads.
In terms of what we could
have done better.
Looking back, things could have
gone a lot more smoothly
had we engaged YouTube much
earlier in the process.
Had we done that, we might have
been able to figure out
something a little bit more
streamlined and a little bit
more user-friendly in terms of
linking your YouTube accounts.
And the fact that we didn't have
a decent codec on Xbox
kind of hurt things.
Well, not kind of.
It did hurt things.
The Motion JPEG encodings were
so large, and because they do
have to go through DemonWare,
we just couldn't allow clips
longer than 30 seconds.
And because of platform parity,
we couldn't allow it
even on platforms that did
have better encoders.
We've since added WebM encoding
to one of the recent
title updates for Call of Duty:
Black Ops, so we will be
looking at relaxing that
30 second limit.
That's absolutely not a
YouTube limitation.
They've been asking us for
longer videos since the
feature became available.
That's something we need to
work through on our side.
What we learned after we
launched was we really should
have had somebody ready
to engage the
community on day one.
Because we didn't have a lot
of time to really put this
together and build a proper UI
around it, we had a lot of
user confusion about uploads.
We had users posting comments on
the YouTube channel about,
hey you stole my video.
That's my video.
They didn't understand that when
they uploaded the video
without having a linked account,
it was going to go to
this shared account that
wasn't theirs.
We could have really done a much
better job of engaging
the community and educating
the community early.
It took us probably two or three
weeks to get branding up
on the channels, which probably
also hurt the
messaging on that.
You go to this YouTube channel
that has all these videos,
some of which are yours.
And it looks like just anybody
else's YouTube channel.
It doesn't look like an official
Call of Duty channel.
I think that added to the
confusion as well.
Really until we did a similar
presentation at GDC in this,
we haven't done a whole lot
of PR on the feature.
It's kind of buried in the UI.
We didn't really talk about it
much with the gaming press.
So we really could have done a
much better job of talking
about the feature and really
letting people know how cool
it is that they can go into Call
of Duty: Black Ops and
make these videos.
Now we're going to see some
samples that people have--
these are straight out of the
game, straight to YouTube
using the exact mechanisms
we talked about before.
I think the first one is an Xbox
video, and I believe the
second one is a PS3 video.
[VIDEO GAME SOUNDS]
DOUG MUIR: And this is a
Tomahawk killing a helicopter.
[VIDEO GAME SOUNDS]
DOUG MUIR: I've been told to
remind everybody that feedback
goes to the URL right there.
The QR code is also a link
to the feedback link.
Or you can use the hashtags to
give us feedback that way.
And I believe we're ready
for questions now.
[APPLAUSE]
DOUG MUIR: Cliff and Kenji, do
you guys want to come on up?
Cliff's coming.
Kenji is too cool for it.
Are there any questions?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
That's a good talk.
I'm an Android game developer
actually.
Do you have any advice on how
one might implement this sort
of thing with Android games,
letting users record their
video and share it?
DOUG MUIR: So the question was
for an Android developer, how
to implement a similar
feature for Android.
Well, the first thing I'll say
is the whole bit about
capturing the game play and
rendering it out, kind of
falls on you.
I mean that's going to be
different for each game.
I don't know what your
rendering engine is.
Beyond that though, the upload
and the linking with YouTube
actually could probably be
pretty smooth on Android
because you do have a browser
and even embedded web views
that you could use
to do the linking
right inside your game.
So that any user can
immediately, the first time
upload straight to his YouTube
account and have
it work that way.
If that's an option to you, I
would definitely recommend
that because it works.
And it was fantastic that we
were able to let people upload
their videos without having
to have a YouTube account.
But it did cause all kinds of
confusion for, who is this guy
who's got all these videos,
and why is he
taking them from me?
So if you can get people to
upload straight to their own
YouTube account right from the
beginning, that's definitely
what I would recommend.
AUDIENCE: Wow.
Yeah.
Thank you.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah.
I would like to add that on
Android, you have account
manager, so you can actually
obtain the authorization
tokens much easier than what
we have demonstrated.
And I see two approaches that
people have been trying.
There's already some titles that
have this functionality.
One that I kind of like is this
little application called
Talking Tom by a company
called Outfit7.
My daughter really likes
to play with it.
It's basically a cat.
You can talk to it, and
it talks back to you.
It actually has a YouTube
upload capability.
So you can hit a camera button,
and they do the
rendering and encoding.
They push it up to YouTube.
So we get a fair amount
of Talking Tom videos.
Then others have been thinking
about, can you actually do the
rendering and encoding
in the cloud?
So ship the states over
to the cloud and do
the encoding there.
You could then be
very creative.
You could do it in
high resolution.
You could do it in 3-D.
It opens up a whole range
of possibilities.
AUDIENCE: Oh yeah.
And the streaming game play
events could be very small.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Thanks.
VINAY: Hi.
My name is Vinay.
I have a question.
Do you have custom search
features on the website?
DOUG MUIR: So the question is,
do we have custom search
features on the website?
YouTube doesn't have any
custom search features.
We do add some keywords to the
videos when we upload them.
Most of the meta-information
that we tag is actually with
developer tags.
And we do have plans for using
the developer tags that we
attach when we upload the video,
but there's nothing
that you can see
using that yet.
But there definitely is
a way to do that.
All of the videos that have
been uploaded have been
annotated with developer tags
that we are planning on using
at some point in the future.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I have two questions.
One is, can you bypass a
workaround the browser
verification.
So if you're playing let's say
on the PS3, is there a way
that you don't have to force the
player out of the game to
go and authenticate
his account?
And the second question is, is
there any way you can stream
from YouTube to the game?
So again, on the console, like
let's say PS3, is there a way
you can take a stream
and just play it?
DOUG MUIR: PS3 in Jarek
might probably--
Sorry.
The question was, is there a way
to bypass the going to the
browser and linking
the account?
And also is there
a way to stream
back to the game console?
And Jarek might be able
to talk a little
bit more about this.
But on the PS3 actually, they
do have native platform APIs
for uploading to YouTube and
linking your account in the
Xross Media Bar.
So ahead of time or
even in game.
Xbox is really the one where
that's not available.
And because we are a
cross-platform game and trying
to present the same experience
across all the platforms we
support, we kind of work with
the lowest common denominator.
It's possible now that we've
done the feature once that we
would have a different
implementation path for PS3
versus Xbox going forward.
But again because of how late
this all came together, we
just stuck with a common
path for both.
In terms of streaming back to
the console, I believe it is
possible, but I don't know if
there's any convenient APIs
for doing it.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
Two quick notes.
So back to PS3.
So the former actually
has the capability.
The problem is it still uses
ClientLogin for authorization
and authentication, which is
something that the entire
industry is really
moving away from.
So that is still
an open issue.
And for YouTube accounts, you
see more and more cases where
ClientLogin will not
be sufficient.
For example, if you enabled
two-factor authentication on
your account, that might
actually prevent ClientLogin
access because the box doesn't
implement that flow.
There's a number-- we actually
have a blog post about all the
different cases that we
know of today that
ClientLogin can fail.
And then on the streaming inside
of the game, this is
something that we've been
thinking about.
But probably we would need
to know a little
more about the context.
So we're going to hang
around after this.
If you would like to talk to
us a little more about what
you have in mind, then we could
definitely look into that.
VINAY: Thank you.
I have another question.
As I understand, the flow is
from the game the video is
uploaded to your backend servers
and from the servers
it is uploaded to the YouTube.
So the bottleneck really is how
much upload your backend
servers can handle rather than
how much YouTube can handle.
So is there a way that you can
directly upload to YouTube?
DOUG MUIR: Absolutely.
On the PS3 that absolutely would
have been an option.
It's rendered on the console
for every platform.
And Sony has no first party
limitations about talking to
the internet basically.
Microsoft does have some first
party rules about who you're
allowed to talk to
from your game.
I don't know if you're
familiar with it.
But you have to go through the
live service platform gateway,
which ours lives at DemonWare.
So we sort of have to stream
through them no matter what.
And again because of simplicity,
we just decided to
do it the same way on both
platforms. But without that
limitation, we absolutely would
have been able to upload
directly to YouTube.
Now the tricky bit in that case
though would be knowing
the OAuth tokens because our
consoles don't have them.
Those are stored at DemonWare.
So if we were going to be
uploading directly to YouTube
from the console, we would have
to have some mechanism.
Probably when you log into our
backends, we would then have
to send the console your OAuth
tokens so that the console
could go directly there.
So going through DemonWare did
impose a bottleneck on us.
But it also gave us a single
point where we could store the
OAuth tokens and deal with
all the upload logic
and work that way.
VINAY: Sorry.
If I may extend.
The question was mainly in terms
of the infrastructure
that you need to have. Right?
So probably one of the reasons
that you went with YouTube is
that you don't have to
have the whole lot of
infrastructure.
But still you have to have a
scaled-down version or-- and
so was that--
DOUG MUIR: Well I
mean yes and no.
I mean, Call of Duty already
has a fairly large backend
infrastructure just because of
the size of our community.
I don't know how much I'm
actually allowed to say at a
public place like this.
But suffice it to say that
there are hundreds of
thousands of Call of Duty
matches going on every day.
And so we already have a fairly
large infrastructure
for dealing with that.
The video bandwidth is actually
not a large part of
what's going on.
It's only a bottleneck because
of all the other bandwidth--
because of all the other traffic
hitting our backends
just as part of running
the Call of Duty
multi-player service.
VINAY: Thank you.
DOUG MUIR: Any other
questions?
AUDIENCE: I'm not sure
if I missed this.
But is there going to be a way
for users to authenticate
themselves, to upload videos
that's not ClientLogin and
doesn't require a browser?
DOUG MUIR: So the question is,
is there a way to authenticate
for uploading videos that's not
ClientLogin, that doesn't
require a browser.
And as far as I know,
the answer to that
right now is no.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: My guess is
in the future there will be.
Because ultimately that's
probably what you would want.
DOUG MUIR: Yeah, I mean, we
would love it absolutely.
But right now I don't believe
there is a way to do it that
doesn't involve a browser
at some stage.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I think
when it comes to kind of
standards-based solutions that
we've been tracking, I don't
see anything.
So the OAuth 2.0 device profile
in beta is probably
the closest we've gotten to
something that takes you away
from the device in the
standards way.
You could certainly think of
a proprietary mechanism to
achieve that.
We haven't been taking advantage
like of people's
smartphones, for example,
for that.
So there's many mechanisms that
one could envision, but
when it comes to kind of
standards-based approaches, I
don't see anything right now.
DOUG MUIR: The good news is
that with OAuth 2.0 device
profile, you could do it all
without leaving your couch if
you have a smartphone or
something like that, which
will be an increasingly
common use case.
AUDIENCE: Because I guess that's
kind of one of the
reasons why, despite its
insecurity, people still use
ClientLogin because ultimately
it does-- from the user's
perspective, it does make it
flow a little bit more
straightforward.
Right?
But then of course there's
the security.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Right.
Yeah.
But less secure.
Right?
DOUG MUIR: And the problem
with something like
ClientLogin--
the potential problem would be,
you don't necessarily want
to be storing those credentials
on the console.
So now you're asking the user
to log in every time
they want to upload.
Whereas with the OAuth
solution, we do
that linking once.
And then until the user revokes
those tokens, we can
use them to act on the
user's behalf.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: One thing
that I didn't cover in the
flow is actually OAuth has a
way to refresh the token.
So you don't actually have to
go through the entire flow.
There's a refresh token that can
be stored on the device.
And then when the access token
expires or is close to
expiration, it can actually
do the dance again.
And typically the ClientLogin
tokens, their life
may not be as long.
So then you have to renew
it or refresh it.
But in order to do that, you
either have to prompt the user
again, or you keep their
credentials.
And storing their credentials
is always--
I mean, any developer that
builds these types of
applications tries to avoid
it as much as fire because
there's so many things that can
go wrong with if you store
their credentials.
AUDIENCE: I had a question
for you, Doug.
You said that you guys were
using a lot of the metadata in
terms of adding developer tags
and looking forward to new
ways to engage those videos
that users have uploaded.
My question was, how much
optimization did you guys do
in terms of search terms and
keywords that users might be
looking for for the videos
as they were uploaded?
So were you guys thinking about
how people are going to
find these videos on YouTube?
Or was it just kind of like
they name it whatever they
named it, and then it goes up,
and the Call of Duty community
creates the browsing structure
for its own community to find
those videos?
DOUG MUIR: Right.
So the question is--
if I were to paraphrase--
is, how much optimization have
we done on the keywords that
we attached to the videos as
we upload them to make it
easier for users
to find videos.
And the answer to that
unfortunately is almost none.
We upload your title that
you attach in the game.
We attach your gamertag
to that as well.
The developer tags, which we
have some plans for, but we're
not using yet, do contain a
little bit more information.
Things like other users in the
videos, the map, the game
mode, things like that.
But those are not visible
to the YouTube channel.
But yeah, in terms of that--
and that's sort of another
place where we probably should
have been a little bit more
ready in terms of engaging
the community.
We could do a whole lot on our
backend when we upload to
organize channels, organize
playlists and really curate
our channel.
And right now, we're not doing
really any of that.
I don't know who has worked in
the game industry before, but
there's always something else
that seems higher priority
than those sorts of tasks.
So hopefully we'll get to it.
AUDIENCE: It seems like
you guys are doing
pretty good, so--
DOUG MUIR: Yeah.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I would like
to add one thing is, even
though, as Doug mentioned, there
wasn't necessarily a lot
of emphasis on optimization,
if you go back to the slide
that he was showing where most
of the views were actually
from YouTube.
That means that users were able
to find their content.
And in fact when we were looking
through the data, it
looked like a lot of the views
were actually related videos.
So when you watch a video on
YouTube, at the end we show
related videos.
So we were able to still kind
of figure out what is the
content relevant to
these uploads.
And then keep them within
this set of videos.
So in the end, it worked out
even though maybe it wasn't so
[INTERPOSING VOICES]--
DOUG MUIR: I think we could do
more to support it and more to
sort of curate our
YouTube channels.
But we're fantastically
happy with it so far.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All right.
We have two more minutes.
So if there are no more
questions, thank you very much
for coming.
Enjoy the rest of Google I/O.
Thank you.
DOUG MUIR: Thank you.